[Music]
all right welcome back
so in the last lecture we derived or
discussed what it means for a function f
of z to be analytic
which are very special functions in the
complex plane
that you can do calculus on where you
can take derivatives and do integrals
and where the derivative specifically
is defined
uh regardless of what approach you take
to take that infinitesimal delta z goes
to zero so you know the derivative is
the limit
of delta f over delta z as delta z goes
to zero but because my variable z has a
real and an imaginary part
i could take the limit as delta x goes
to zero on the real axis or as delta y
goes to zero on the imaginary axis
and those two notions of the derivative
have to be equal to each other for that
that derivative to be well defined for
df dz to be a function of z and not be
you know uh kind of beholden or
dependent on what approach vector or or
kind of you know approach direction i
took to take that derivative
and so we actually computed you know
what is the derivative if i freeze delta
y equals zero and take the limit as
delta x goes to zero or if i freeze
delta x equals zero and i take the limit
in the imaginary axis as delta y goes to
zero
and those are two different expressions
in terms of a complex function let's say
f
of z
equals u of
x y plus i
v of x y
remember z equals x plus i y
and so my complex punk function has a
real and an imaginary part a real
function u and an imaginary function v
and those functions if i take the
derivative df dz kind of on the real
axis approach
then i get partial u partial x plus i
partial v partial x and if i take the
derivative in the direction of you know
delta y going to zero i get that this
derivative is partial v partial y minus
i partial u partial y
and so for that derivative to be
independent of the path i take that
delta z goes to zero these have to be
equal which means the real part have to
be equal
and the imaginary part have to be equal
and these are equalities in terms of the
partial derivatives of the real and
imaginary part
of f with respect to the real and
imaginary part of z
and if this is satisfied then my
function is analytic these are called
the koshi riemann conditions
super duper duper important okay
and so what we're going to say is so
that's just a recap of last time that
you know my function f of z
which has a real part and an imaginary
part this function will be analytic if
it is single valued if it's not
multi-valued like z to the one half or
log of z if it's single valued
and if these koshi riemann conditions
hold for the real and imaginary part if
these hold
then this derivative df dz is
independent of the direction that i take
delta z equal to zero good very cool
stuff
and examples of functions that are
analytic that we see all the time are
things like you know z squared z cubed z
to the fourth any monomial or polynomial
in z
any function that has a convergent
taylor series like e to the z cosine of
z sine of z
and even some exotic functions like
log of z or z to the one half or z to
the one third
if i take them on their principal branch
and i exclude the origin which is kind
of a very important singular point that
is not analytic and
that that i'll talk about later in the
next few lectures but things like z
squared z cubed z to the fourth e to the
z cosine z sine z those functions are
analytic everywhere they're called
entire functions because they're
entirely analytic everywhere in the
complex plane and they have very very
important properties
that the real part and the imaginary
part of those functions are solutions of
laplace's equations the laplace partial
differential equation that comes up all
the time
in the heat equation in electrostatics
you know in fluid mechanics so that's
what i'm going to show today so uh if
f of z
is uh analytic
and analytic
not catalytic analytic
and both u and v are twice
differentiable and
u comma v both
twice differentiable
this is kind of like sometimes
mathematicians get almost a little bit
lawyerly where you know you have to be
really really careful about the specific
conditions that that hold like of course
i'm going to be taking another
derivative of these expressions so i
need them to be twice differentiable so
i'm going to write that into my little
legal contract that we're all going to
sign if f z is analytic and u and v both
twice differentiable
then
essentially what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take this koshy riemann
condition
and i am going to
take its derivative with respect to x
and i'm going to take its derivative
with respect to y and we're going to see
what happens
so uh so i'm going to take kind of koshi
riemann one i think this is koshi
riemann one let's call this
cr1
and just to be fun with colors we're
going to call this
cr2
okay
and the koshi riemann
first condition
is going to be i'm going to take a
partial u partial x equals partial
v partial y
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take its partial with respect to x i'm
going to take partial of both sides with
respect to x
and i'm going to get that partial
squared u partial x squared
equals partial
squared v
partial x partial y okay that's what
happens if i take the partial of both
sides with respect to x
this is definitely true
and now i'm going to look at koshi
riemann 2 what we're going to do is
we're going to compute some derivatives
and then we're going to you know
make some things equal to each other and
we're going to show
that the u function is a solution of
laplace's equation and we're going to
show that the v function is also a
solution of laplace's equation
so now koshi riemann two
i'm going to take koshi riemann 2 which
is uh
maybe i'll just mix this up so this is
you know partial uh
u partial y
equals minus partial v partial x and i'm
guessing i'm going to take the partial
of this with respect to y that just
feels right
sometimes you gotta trust your gut or
try something and maybe it doesn't work
and this is going to equal if i take the
partial of this with respect to y i get
partial squared u partial y squared
equals minus partial squared v
partial
x
partial y partial you know i take the
partial of this with respect to y it's
partial squared v partial x partial y
okay so now what i have is that you know
partial u squared with respect to x and
partial u squared with respect to y
equal
equal and opposite things okay and so
what this means
this is actually super simple this means
maybe i'll go yellow again here
because partial squared v partial x
partial y appears on both the right hand
sides
this equals minus this
this equals minus the same thing
so partial squared u partial x squared
equals minus partial squared u partial y
squared
and if i add this to both sides i get
partial squared u
partial x squared plus partial squared u
partial y squared equals zero
this is
laplace's equation
del squared u equals zero
equals zero factorial also
so this is uh super duper important
if i have a function uh f which is
analytic
meaning its derivative is defined and
finite and it doesn't matter what
direction delta z goes to zero if these
koshi riemann conditions are satisfied
which is essentially synonymous with
being analytic
then you can kind of manipulate these
koshi riemann conditions and take some
partials and set some things equal and
you find that the real valued function u
the real part of f
is a solution of laplace's equation
this is called a harmonic function okay
so uh
then you know u
is a harmonic
function that's kind of what we mean
when it's the solution of
uh of laplace's equation the solutions
of laplace equations are called harmonic
functions the real part u is a harmonic
function it's a solution of laplace's
equation
good uh just for practice i'm going to
show you how you would also derive the
same thing for the imaginary part for
the v part i'm guessing again this is
just intuition i'm going to take these
exact same conditions and instead of
taking partial partial x of the first
one and partial partial y of the second
one i'm going to flip those and i'll get
some other expression i can turn into a
solution of vulpoce's equation so let's
do that real quick uh just for you know
for the sake of completement uh
completeness
same thing uh koshi riemann one is
partial
maybe i'll stick with some colors here
it is um
we have partial u partial x
equals partial v partial y
again i think now i'm going to take
partial partial y of this partial
partial y and i get uh you know partial
squared u
partial x partial y sorry it's so
squeaky i know it drives some of you
crazy
equals now this is partial squared v
partial y squared that's good that's
what i want
right this is now i want an expression
that's in terms of the second partial
derivatives of v the imaginary part so i
got that here
and koshy riemann 2 i'll make this in
pink so koshi riemann 2
is going to be uh partial u partial y
equals minus partial v partial x
and similarly instead of taking the y
derivative now i'm going to take partial
partial x
and i'm going to get you know partial
squared
u
partial x partial y
equals minus partial squared v
partial x squared
and actually i think this one's even
easier because now you know the
left-hand sides are equal to each other
so i don't even have to do any you know
mental carry the negative one
this blue expression equals this pink
expression
so i have uh
you know partial squared
v
partial x squared minus
equals partial squared v partial y
squared and so if i add this partial
squared
x to both sides
i get you know partial squared v partial
x squared the partial derivative the
second partial derivative of v with
respect to x
plus the second partial derivative of v
with respect to y equals zero
again
v is a solution of laplace's equation
so partial squared v
equals zero as well let's give it two
exclamation marks as well so v
is also
a harmonic
function
meaning it's a solution of laplace's
equation it is a harmonic function very
very interesting okay so this is pretty
cool right partial differential
equations are everywhere they are
absolutely ubiquitous laplace's equation
is particularly important this equation
comes up in every branch of physics when
you're solving the steady state heat
distribution use laplace's equation
when you are solving for the
electrostatic uh potential or for you
know the gravitational potential or for
a potential flow for an incompressible
irrotational flow you're going to be
solving laplace's equation
and the neat thing is
is that
solutions of laplace's equation happen
to be the real and imaginary part of
these magic special analytic functions
so if i take you know something like uh
i don't know if i take
f of z equals z squared which we know is
analytic we've shown this as analytic
and this equals you know uh
x plus i y quantity squared that equals
x squared minus y squared
plus i times 2 x y
i claim that this you know imagine this
real part u this function u
and this function v
are both solutions of laplace's equation
you can verify you can actually verify
that if you take this function u and
plug it in here this solves laplace's
equation and if you take this function v
and plug it in here it also solves the
plosis equation really easy to verify
you can try this for f of z equals z
cubed or z to the fourth or z to the
fifth you'll get this kind of pascal
triangle pattern of x and y's and those
functions are going to be solutions of
of laplace's equation same thing with
the real and the imaginary part of the
exponential function the cosine function
the sine function
and so on and so forth any analytic
function and so that's really really
cool is that there is a deep deep
connection between the solution of one
of the most important partial
differential equations you know ever
written down laplace's equation
and these very special
complex functions called analytic
functions good
okay um so i think what i want to do now
is
that's kind of the main main thrust of
this lecture so now what i'm going to do
for the rest of the time is i'm going to
derive what these koshi riemann
conditions would look like in polar
coordinates because that's kind of cool
and then i'm going to give you a couple
of important theorems that are true for
complex functions that we're going to
use later when we do things like contour
integrals so i think the next few
lectures are going to be so we talked
about derivatives in the complex plane
the next few uh lectures we're going to
talk about integrals in the complex
plane when we start doing you know path
integrals and contour integrals these
are kind of a complex baby version of
things like gauss's theorem and stokes's
theorem you know so green's theorem is
derived in the complex plane and we're
going to see what happens when we
integrate analytic functions and
non-analytic functions
good uh so what do i want to show you
right now um
so i'm going to write down koshi riemann
in polar coordinates
so let's say
koshi riemann
koshi
riemann i wish i knew how to spell i
think this has two m's please forgive me
koshi and riemann
riemann conditions
in
polar
coordinates
good
and so essentially what we're going to
be doing is we're going to be saying um
and this is super weird we're going to
take
uh you know we're going to take f of
z
equals u it still has a real part but
we're going to write u as a function of
r and theta
plus i v which is a function of r and
theta
where you know z equals r e to the i
theta is written in polar coordinates so
it's kind of weird because i'm still
writing my function f
in kind of cartesian real plus i
imaginary but i'm writing the argument z
in polar coordinates you could do the
other way you could say f of z equals
you know u e to the iv
and you could have that be a function of
r and theta or of x and y so there's
actually multiple ways of kind of
you know you can write z in polar and f
and cartesian you can write z in polar
and f in polar you can write z in
cartesian and f in polar and you can
derive kind of four different versions
of the koshirimon conditions if you are
a masochist okay good
um
so koshiriman and polar is going to be
something to the effect of
partial u partial r
the squeakiness actually i find very
reassuring uh means i've been writing
equals one over r partial v partial
theta that's one of the cauchy riemann
conditions
and
um
partial v partial r
equals minus 1 over r
partial u partial theta
and again
if you were going to be solving
laplace's equation in polar coordinates
if you were dealing with the steady
state heat distribution so this would be
good these uh
rectangular coordinates would be good to
find solutions of laplace's equation
for things like the steady state heat
distribution or the electrostatic
distribution you know in on a rectangle
and a rectangular coordinate system but
if i wanted to find the steady state
heat distribution for a circular plate
of metal that i'm heating at the
boundaries
uh then i would be wanting to use the
polar form of the koshi roman conditions
which are again going to give me
solutions of laplace's equation but in
polar coordinates which is kind of neat
um
and you know there's always simplifying
notation if we define
u sub r equals partial u partial r and
if we define you know u sub theta equals
partial u partial theta and so on and so
forth so subscript here is partial
derivative
uh then this expression here
you know in in that notation becomes
kind of nice and simple
it becomes
uh let's write it out u sub r
equals minus 1 over r
v sub theta
and v sub r equals minus 1 over r u sub
theta and i'm only writing it these two
ways because you know you're going to
see mathematicians use whatever
shorthand they particularly like or
physicists or engineers and sometimes
people use subscripts for partial
derivatives so i just want you to kind
of see these are you know the exact same
thing just written with different
notation
um
[Music]
good okay um so those are the koshy
riemann conditions in polar coordinates
you can derive i think what you really
should do is you should actually compute
the derivative of this you know as r
goes to zero and and do kind of you can
kind of derive these that'll require a
little bit of thought of how you can
relate the cartesian
koshi riemann conditions to these polar
koshi riemann conditions but you
certainly can derive these
i think what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to actually show you that log of z
is analytic away from the origin using
these polar koshi riemann conditions and
then i'm going to give you those
integral theorems that i talked about
earlier
so i'm probably going to fast forward as
i erase all of this nonsense
it's actually not nonsense it's super
important
okay so
what i'm going to do now this is kind of
a piece of this lecture
is i'm going to verify
that
log
of z
is in fact analytic
away from z equals zero
away
from z equals zero remember the log of z
is a weird function it's infinitely
valued um
and i'm just going to write it down so
like log of z
log of z equals i'm going to write it
down
in exactly this form okay so that that's
why i'm deriving koshi riemann
in terms of the real plus imaginary part
of f
but in polar coordinates for z so the
log of z equals the real value logarithm
of
r
plus
i times
theta principle
and we know that there's a plus uh two
pi
you know k where k is an integer that is
also valid here but remember this is
again a legalistic kind of technical
math detail and and sometimes it's
important to be legalistic with things
analytic functions have to be single
valued so when i take about when i talk
about the log of z being analytic away
from the origin what i technically mean
is you know this log function if i look
at x and y and i look at the v component
this log function is like a spiral
staircase an infinite spiral staircase
where every time i go around i get you
know i can add 2 pi
you know 2 pi 4 pi 6 pi 8 pi
in the phase or i can subtract 2 pi 4 pi
so you know going up or going down
we are specifically talking about only
the principal angle the principal
logarithm where theta is in zero to two
pi okay so that's kind of the first
level of this infinite spiral staircase
i don't know if any of you like stephen
king or the dark tower but whenever i
think of the i think the dark tower is
basically a complex logarithm maybe he
took a complex analysis class in college
and we're only on the first level that's
where humans live in this principal
branch of the complex logarithm
good so i'm just gonna we're talking
about this uh principal branch of the
complex logarithm and i'm gonna get rid
of the p and i'm just gonna call this
theta to make my life a lot simpler
we're on the principal branch of the
complex logarithm theta is between 0 and
2 pi
and so as long as i talk about that
branch this log function is analytic
away from z equals zero and we're going
to verify that using these koshi riemann
conditions so again that's why i wrote
it in this weird kind of
way where this is u of r theta
and this is v of r
theta and it's kind of nice because you
know uh
u is only a function of r and v is only
a function of theta so you're going to
see that kind of trivially
uh this is actually true
and we'll we'll just do that so kind of
clearly
um we have that u sub theta because u is
only a function of r partial u partial
theta equals zero
and because v is only a function of
theta partial v
uh
partial v partial r is also equal to
zero
that's certainly true
and u sub r
if i take the partial of this with
respect to r it's just one over r
and v sub theta
equals 1. okay
so
let's just kind of verify these two
koshi riemann conditions so koshi
riemann 1
is that partial u partial r
i don't know why i use capital r here
and lower case r here i'm sorry that's
super confusing these r's are all the
same they should all be capital r's
you know big r
big r
big r i don't know what's wrong with me
big r big r big r those are all big r's
um sorry this is a mess
but you get what i'm saying those are
radii koshi riemann one
partial u partial r
is one over r from here and that equals
one over r times partial v partial theta
which is one
yes in fact one over r equals one over r
away from r equals zero
um good
and then koshy riemann 2
this one partial v partial r
equals you know definitely partial v
partial r
equals
minus one over r partial
u partial theta zero equals zero also
true
uh you know one over r
v theta this is also true because those
are both zero
both of these are true
as long
away
from
r equals 0. because i have this 1 over r
something weird happens when r equals 0
this but these koshi riemann conditions
are absolutely satisfied and these are
exactly equal to each other and there's
no weirdness as long as r is greater
than zero as long as i'm away from that
origin
if i'm at the origin i would probably
have to do something like l'hopital and
verify that in fact these are are not
valid these do not hold that function
that derivative d
d d z of log of z equals one over z
uh blows up to infinity at z equals zero
so it's not it does not exist at z
equals zero
but log of z has a derivative uh where
it it is independent of the direction of
that derivative
uh for all z away from the origin at
least on its principal branch so log of
z is in fact analytic on its principal
branch away from the origin very
important point we're going to use that
later when we do complex contour
integrals
um
and if i was uh you know thinking about
this i would want you to actually really
show from these conditions that you can
derive these conditions and vice versa i
would write something like you know r
equals r squared equals x squared plus y
squared
um you know and theta equals um
maybe like
you know co r cos theta equals x and r
sine theta equals y and i would try to
compute partial derivatives and and show
that these equalities are e are the
equivalent and necessary and sufficient
for these equalities to be true that
would be like a really nice exercise if
you're actually taking this class in my
in my math class that probably is going
to be one of the exercises i ask you
and you know it's it's probably a good
30 minute or 60 minute exercise
if you're pretty fresh on your calculus
if you're a little rusty you know it
probably would take me about two hours
right now to really uh nail that down
okay so now that's why i'm not doing it
right here on this light board
good so what have we done we've shown
that the koshi riemann conditions are
solutions of laplace's equation
uh sorry these functions u and v are the
solutions of laplace's equation if they
satisfy koshi riemann we have derived
koshiriman and polar coordinates we
didn't derive it i have written it down
and i have asked you to derive it big
difference
and we have shown that if you believe
that this is true
then that we can use that to show that
the complex logarithm is in fact
analytic
um
away from the origin and on its
principal branch where it's single
valued okay so i basically take the
spiral staircase and i cut out the first
level of that spiral staircase and i i
you know only analyze that if i was
being again a legalistic mathematician
i'd give this a name like
you know fancy log on level one you know
something like that i just make up some
notation that we're only talking about
that first level of stephen king's dark
tower
but very important this is going to be
super useful this property that complex
log is analytic everywhere away from
zero
specifically what that's going to allow
us to do is in the complex plane
if i'm giving you the punch line for a
couple of lectures in the future
if i have a closed contour c1
and i have another closed contour
c2
what i claim
is that the inner integral of c1 of log
my fancy pants log on the first level
log of z
d z
because
log is analytic here
analytic log is analytic in this domain
log is not analytic everywhere inside of
this curve but it is analytic here so
this integral is going to equal zero
and what i claim is that on this second
contour the integral on the second
contour that has this weird singularity
point
of log z
dz
that's going to equal 2 pi i okay
because if i go around in a circle
around that origin i climbed and i added
2 pi i to my phase angle so i'm going to
pick up a 2 pi i here this is
essentially koshi's integral formula
very very important when you do things
like try to compute inverse laplace
transforms and things like that you can
solve some pretty hairy integrals using
this kind of weird idea of integrating
around singularities
but if i integrate my logarithm anywhere
else that doesn't contain this this uh
this point everything is well behaved
and fine so i'm gonna have like a whole
lecture dedicated to this i just wanted
to give you the punch line and kind of
anticipate what we're going to see later
why we care about things like analytic
functions and points where things are
not analytic and things like that
good um
okay
uh
so there's probably one or two more
things i want to show you um
these are properties of analytic
functions
and how we are going to use them in the
future based on the fact that they have
taylor series so i'm going to state
these properties now
and then
i'm going to use these properties in
future lectures okay and i feel like
complex analysis is uh really quite
interesting it's a very fascinating
field like if you like calculus
you're probably going to like complex
analysis and my students are usually
kind of polarized some of them they're
very polarized so some of them love
complex analysis some of them hate
complex analysis
i'm a little bit more ambivalent because
i think it's super duper interesting
and 50 years ago it was the primary way
that we thought about solutions of
partial differential equations before
computers when we were stuck with pencil
and paper
complex functions is was one of our
gateways to opening up partial
differential equations and it still kind
of is we still
benefit from that intuition even though
now we can solve these things with
computers so again i'm a little torn i
don't teach a 15 week you know full
semester class on complex but i do have
this intense two week boot camp because
there's deep intuitive things that you
need to know
that said these things are kind of
confusing right it's hard to picture we
can picture things in three dimensions
but complex variables a complex function
that has a real part and an imaginary
part over a variable that has a real
part and an imaginary port that's like a
four-dimensional space we don't really
picture it and it's pretty confusing
so i'm going to encourage you to really
you know take your time and review these
concepts you might need to
play these back or or do some examples
on pencil and paper and really think
about these things
um
good okay
i'm gonna erase this and then we're
gonna jump forward um to the the thing i
wanna tell you
okay
so last thing i want to tell you um are
these integral sorry not integral
theorems just general theorems
and again um you could if you don't like
theorems if you just want to see how to
use these things maybe this is you know
a little technical and legalistic but
i'm going to do it anyway
theorem 1.
and i've said this a bunch of times in
the last lecture so you might not have
known that this is something that needs
to be proven it's a theorem it needs a
proof i'm not going to prove it
a function
f of z
which has a real and an imaginary part
you know u plus v i sometimes i write iv
sometimes all right v i
okay so this function is going to be
single valued and have partial
derivatives and satisfy koshi riemann
condition
and it is analytic if and only if it
satisfies koshi riemann so a function
f of z
that
is
single valued
and
has continuous
partials
uh partial u partial x partial u partial
y partial v partial x partial v partial
y
so if my function is single valued and
it has continuous partial derivatives
that do in fact exist that are that you
can write down
in a domain remember we're talking about
regions of the complex plane in a domain
d
which may or may not be all of the
complex plane but it's inside the
complex plane that's what this means
it's a subset or equal to the complex
plane
the function
is
analytic
in
d
if
and only if
very important
it is analytic
if the thing i'm going to say is true
and it is only analytic if the thing i'm
about to say is true in math we write
this iff that means if and only if it's
a necessary and sufficiency condition if
you like math speak
if and only if
the koshi riemann conditions
the koshiri
man
have i been spelling it right the whole
time the koshy riemann conditions
are satisfied at every point z in the
domain are satisfied
at every
point
z inside this domain
good okay so i've said this a million
times up until now right we know that
for our function to be analytic for us
to be able to do calculus on it for uh
analytic is the key property that we are
checking uh for this function f of z f
of z is analytic if and only if the
koshi riemann conditions hold that's
what i'm trying to say
our function f of z it needs to be
single valued that's just a definitional
thing it has to be single valued and if
it's partial derivatives of its real and
imaginary parts exist and are finite and
satisfy koshy riemann conditions
then that is necessary for it to be
analytic and that's sufficient for it to
be analytic if this is true then then f
is analytic uh if f is analytic then
this is true that's what that's saying
and you know if you were in a proper
15-week complex analysis course you
would be proving
that this is true there would be like
more under the hood and there's
certainly you know kind of deeper math
there
i want you to be able to use these
things i want you to be able to use
functions that are analytic i want you
to be able to tell when a function is
analytic check the koshi riemann i want
you to know what you can get out of a
function that's analytic like you can
compute its derivatives and you can do
contour integrals around it and i want
you to know what happens that's weird
when a function is not analytic like if
you integrate around the log function
around a closed orbit that contains a
non-analytic point a singularity um
or kind of a degenerate point that the
function is non-analytic so so that's
you know kind of i don't really care
about exactly proving uh that this is or
isn't true to take my word for it or you
know take koshi and riemann's word for
it but i want you to know how to use
this theorem and property because we're
engineers okay
there is some really beautiful
mathematics but i want you to be able to
use these things
the other
theorem let's call this theorem two
and this is uh gorsa's theorem i always
thought that was kind of a cool name
gorsa
theorem uh gorsa's
that's not how you write theorem but
that's the gorsa's theorem
if
f this is a weird one this is a super
super super interesting one if
f of z
is
analytic at z analytic
at z
which means these are true
then f of z
has continuous derivatives
this is going to be weird wait for it it
of all
orders
like not just the first derivative of z
but the second derivative of z and the
19th derivative of z if you like stephen
king we're all about the 19th derivative
all of the derivatives that's bonkers
why is that true all i required here is
that first partial derivatives are equal
or are exist and satisfy koshy riemann
if that's true if my function is
analytic
then this tells me that in a
neighborhood around that point where z
is analytic in this domain d
all derivatives of f of z have to exist
f f double prime exists if triple prime
f you know the 19th derivative the 577th
derivative all exist
in that domain
so that's really interesting it
essentially means that i have continuous
derivatives of all higher orders if my
function is analytic that's unexpected
but very very important
and kind of the main implication of this
the main
implication
is
that um you know f of z
is analytic
if
and only if right or double f if and
only if uh and this is at some point z
naught some you know base point z that
i'm considering
if and only if
its taylor series
uh converges to the function in that
neighborhood exists let's say exists
and
converges
to f of z
in a neighborhood
gotta be in the neighborhood
neighborhood
of
z naught so essentially i have some z
naught i have some neighborhood of z
naught where i have some some z
and what this means is that if my
function f is analytic at this base
point z naught
all of the derivatives are continuous
and exist and the function has a
convergent taylor series in some
neighborhood of that base point which is
really cool it means that if i know z
not and all of the derivatives at this
point i can specify my function value it
anywhere else in this domain that the
function is analytic this is the basis
of something called analytic
continuation and it's really really
interesting it basically means you know
if i have a domain
d that's really big i've got it my
function is analytic on this massive
massive massive domain
and i have a ton of information over
here at z naught i can compute z naught
and its derivative at second third
fourth fifth and so on derivative
it means that i can actually extend and
and define what that function value is
everywhere in this domain i can i can
tell what my function value is here just
from properties over here because it's
analytic
and of course that isn't so surprising
to us in complex in real valued
functions that's kind of how we think of
taylor series in the first place
but here it basically means that we can
do that we can extend kind of our
neighborhood of definition of this
function until we hit
a non-analytic point like maybe there's
a cliff here where you know now it's not
analytic and i can't use those
derivatives after this cliff i lose
information after that cliff or maybe
there's a cusp here and that's where i
lose the ability to extend my function
beyond that point
okay good two very important theorems
and again we're going to think about how
we can use these
to solve integral equations and contour
integrals and things like that in the
next lectures okay thank you